[Musique]
il
bienvenue pour un nouveau numéro de v y
paie vers yvelinoise personnes avec un
versailles et jacques rivoal bonjour
bonjour alors vous avez une vie partagée
entre votre passion pour le rugby est
plus de trente ans de carrière dans
l'automobile sur laquelle on reviendra
juste après mais d'abord donc le rugby
président du groupe d'intérêt public
chargé d'organiser la coupe du monde
2023 en france alors sur quels sont les
travaux actuels par rapport à cette
organisation va écouter c'est le début
d'une formidable aventure puisque la
france a été retenue pour organiser la
coupe du monde ya maintenant un an
il est donc depuis un an ba on a mis en
place dans le cadre de ce comité
d'organisation de la coupe du monde 2023
on a mis en place en fait les fondations
donc tout ce qui tourne autour de la
gouvernance donc un conseil
d'administration une assemblée générale
c'est un nombre de comités et donc on a
on a lancé les travaux avec deux deux
grands axes importants qui ont été le
positionnement de la marque
donc on vient de dévoiler le logo la
signature de la marque qui va être le
fil rouge autour d'eux le duquel on va
communiquer ce qui représente ce logo
alors ce logo en fait il a il a pour but
de de d'exprimer ce qu'on veut
communiquer autour de cet événement
great la coupe du monde deux ans en
france en 2023 et la signature c'est oui
à rugby nous sommes le rugby à l'idée
c'est de dire le rugby c'est pas
uniquement un sport etc le lait les gens
qui portent les valeurs du rugby ce ne
sont pas uniquement les rugbymen ou les
rugbywomen qui ont des crampons et qui
chausse les crampons et qui porte un
maillot mais le rugby c'est des valeurs
très fortes qui traversent la société et
qui sont portés par tout le monde
aujourd'hui dans la société qui veulent
du respect de l'engagement de la
solidarité c'est ça les valeurs du rugby
et c'est pour ça qu'on veut dire
finalement où nous tout le monde et le
rugby donc on aura des ambassadeurs qui
vont communiquer ses messages positifs
autour du rugby dans leurs activités
personnelles et professionnelles alors
c'est la france rurale on le voit dans
le clip 1 la france rurale la france
urbaine finalement ça sera la coupe du
monde de l'ensemble des français
oui là c'est un formidable événement
c'est le troisième événement mondial
après la coupe du monde de football et
les jeux olympiques c'est ces deux
millions quatre cent mille spectateurs
c'est 450 mille visiteurs étrangers qui
vont venir pendant 45 jours
là aussi c'est un événement puisque une
coupe de
de foot c'est 30 jours les jeux
olympiques c'est quinze jours nous
l'événement la fête et va durer 45 jours
et elle va mobiliser pas uniquement
paris bien sûr y aura le stade de france
mais y aura neuf autres villes en france
qui vont accueillir pendant 45 jours des
matches des régions des départements qui
vont accueillir des dans le cadre de
camp de base
les équipes et donc on veut pendant 45
jours pouvoir faire la fête dans toute
la france autour des valeurs et des
vertus très positive que sont celles du
rugby ça sera la deuxième fois de
l'histoire que la france organise la
coupe du monde la première fois c'était
en 2007
alors je dis bien organisés parce
qu'elle a déjà accueilli la coupe du
monde en 1999 avec une coorganisation
avec l'irlande et le pays de galles
quels sont les éléments sur lesquels
vous avez vous allez vous appuyez
justement pour vous différencier de ce
qui s'est passé en 2007
mais d'abord on va s'appuyer sur les
choses très positives qu'on a tiré comme
enseignements de ce qui s'est passé en
2007 le directeur général qui qui
conduit le comité d'organisation était
déjà aux manettes en 2007 donc on a déjà
une bonne une bonne expérience et
beaucoup de gens qu'on va intégrer dans
l'équipe ont déjà le vrai en 2007
et bien sûr on va ce qu'on va essayer de
faire la grande particularité cette
fois-ci par rapport à 2007 c'est qu'on
démarre beaucoup plus tôt on est et on a
été désigné 5 en presque six ans avant
l'événement donc on a le temps de bien
travailler pour faire en sorte que cet
événement profite ensuite au rugby au
rugby français puisque la la le grand
intérêt d'une coupe du monde c'est bien
sûr de célébrer le rugby de faire la
fête autour du rugby mais c'est aussi
d'avoir un événement qui va être
économiquement rentable et tous les
gains de cette opération vont être
entièrement redistribuées au profit du
rugby français donc ça sera des des
moyens pour développer la formation les
la formation des jeunes la formation des
encadrants des dirigeants dans les clubs
d installation du matériel pour
développer le rugby français et ça on
veut le préparer très en amont pour que
l'accueil nord général après une coupe
du monde il ya toujours un
une explosion du nombre de licenciés
qu'on puisse bien accueillir ces jeunes
qui vont être passionné par ce sport et
pouvoir continuer à les accueillir dans
de bonnes conditions alors déjà de
passionnés vous vous les évoquer vous
avez été un jeune passionné vous avez
commencé à l'âge de 14 ans au rugby club
de versailles le rugby comment vous avez
découvert ce sport
pour écoutez moi je suis versaillais
j'habitais versailles et j'étais un
garçon allait on pourrait le qualifier
probablement d'un peu turbulent et donc
je me suis retrouvé entraîné par des
amis
dans ce club de rugby et le rugby m'a
énormément apporté je crois que le rugby
m'a permis de canaliser mon énergie pour
la mettre au service du collectif et ça
a été pour moi une formidable aventure
humaine
le rugby m'a énormément apporté les plus
grandes amitiés que j'ai encore conservé
aujourd'hui elles viennent de cette
époque du rugby à versailles c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui que j'ai un peu plus
de temps je veux redonner au rugby
finalement tout ce que le rugby m'a
apporté on voit l'image des jeunes que
vous entraînez notamment au rugby-club
de versailles c'est comme ça que vous
contribuez à ce que vous êtes au nez le
rugby oui bah moi je suis toujours resté
proche du club de versailles qui est un
beau un beau un beau club un club
historique c'est un des dix clubs les
plus anciens en france et surtout un
club formateur c'est un club qui se
caractérise par sa dimension formation
et en particulier qui est un club qui a
des beaucoup de jeunes en formation et
donc moi j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ça
de pouvoir entraîner des jeunes alors
j'entraîne pas des juniors ou décalés
j'entraîne les tout-petits donc les
laissons appelle les premiers pas donc
ce sont les jeunes qui démarrent qui ont
5 ans 6 ans 7 ans et on est très fier
parce qu'on a beaucoup de jeunes on a
plus de 20 1 20 25 enfants dans les plus
de cinq ans et on doit être le quatrième
club en france
avec ce nombre de licenciés dans cette
catégorie là et donc ça c'est très très
gratifiant très bienveillant de pouvoir
redonner aux jeunes ce que vous a
apporté ce formidable sport alors ce que
lorsque je vous ai présenté j'ai parlé
de votre carrière dans l'automobile on
va là détaillé juste après mais est ce
que le rugby qu'on désigne comme l'école
de la vie c'est utile dans le monde de
l'entreprise et dans le monde des
affaires
oui parce que je crois que le rugby
c'est des valeurs très fortes comme je
le disais tout à l'heure ce qui nous a
surpris lorsqu'on a commencé à
travailler sur finalement l'histoire
qu'on veut raconter autour de cette
coupe du monde on s'interrogeait sur les
bien sûr ce qu'étaient les valeurs du
rugby mais aussi ce qu'étaient les
attentes des jeunes
des gens dans la société en particulier
des fameux millénium qui vont devenir la
catégorie la plus importante et on s'est
rendu compte que les valeurs du rugby
sont des valeurs modernes parce que ces
valeurs elles correspondent aux attentes
de la société les gens vous disent
aujourd'hui nous on veut vivre sans
faire de compromis
on veut s'épanouir dans notre vie
personnelle mais aussi s'épanouir dans
notre vie professionnelle
on veut voyager dans le monde entier
mais on veut avoir un ancrage dans sa
ville dans sa région voilà on veut vivre
intensément et on veut vivre avec du
sens et ça c'est le rugby le rugby porte
ces valeurs là le rugby c'est un
formidable sport dans lequel il ya du
respect on triche pas dans le rugby on
se roule pas par terre on respecte le
rugby l'arbitré ne discute jamais
décisions de larbitre on s'engage
le collectif est déterminant c'est le
c'est un sport collectif mais c'est le
sport collectif où bien sûr il peut y
avoir quelques exploits individuels mais
pour réussir dans le rugby c'est avant
tout le le collectif qui prime
et ça ce sont des valeurs qui sont des
valeurs fortes moderne et qui sont bien
sûr très importante aussi pour réussir
dans l'entreprise c'est pour ça que dans
l'entreprise on aime bien moi j'ai
souvent quand je j'avais recruté des
gens quand on me disait quand un
candidat me parlait de son appétence
pour le rugby ou du fait qu'il joue au
rugby
c'était un point positif ce n'est pas le
seul bien sûr mais c'était quand même
c'était comme un point positif
alors justement on va en parler de votre
carrière vous avez fait des études à
sciences po et après l'heure à l'école
normale supérieure et vous allez
commencer dans le secteur de
l'automobile en tant que vendeur à
mantes-la-jolie dans les yvelines vous
savoir justement dans les yvelines
est-ce que vous pouvez revenir sur cette
période en tant que vendeur ça a été
quelque chose d'assez
assez surprenant je m'apprêtais pas du
tout a démarré dans cette fonction là je
vais travailler dans les ressources
humaines en fait de l'entreprise renault
et puis pour un concours de
circonstances ça pas pu être possible et
donc on m'a proposé de rentrer dans la
fonction commerciale et j'ai dit ok
pourquoi pas bon coup j'y vais et je me
suis retrouvé du jour au lendemain comme
face au rang de science po normal sud
dans une succursale à mantes-la-jolie
avec des vendeurs il a fallu que pendant
un an je je trouve que j'étais capable
de vendre des voitures ce que j'ai
réussi à faire ont ensuite j'ai fait
carrière au sein de l'entreprise mais
j'ai vraiment commencé c'était là
l'école de formation de vente renault
ont commencé à la base comme dans
beaucoup d'autres secteurs pour vraiment
connaître ce qu'est le client et la
vraie vente sur le secteur 26 ans dans
le groupe renault où vous avez gravi les
échelons jusqu'à devenir directeur
général de renault en allemagne entre
2000 et 2009 et ensuite directeur g 4
donc vous vous occupiez du marché
espagnol italien allemand et britannique
comment vous comment vous avez vécu ce
parcours cette ascension parce que vous
êtes parti de vendeurs pour atteindre
dès la hiérarchie le haut de la
hiérarchie
oui bah ça a été un vraiment j'ai pris
du plaisir pendant pendant 25 ans 26 ans
chez renault
j'ai alterné des postes siège terrain
étranger france toutes les fonctions du
de toutes les dimensions de la fonction
ventes et marketing
donc j'ai été vraiment gâtés dans ma vie
professionnelle tous les deux trois ans
j'avais un nouveau challenge et en
particulier donc quand on aime un peu
l'automobile pouvoir travailler en
allemagne et à de patron d'une marque
2-2 même abandonné dans ce pays là
c'était une aventure fantastique donc
j'ai vraiment moi été gâté par la vie
professionnelle j'ai appris beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup donné mais j'ai été
vraiment très très bien très heureux
dans ma vie professionnelle
alors justement vous parlez d'un autre
constructeur ces vols zakhem que vous
avez vous rejoint en 2010 pourquoi vous
avez choisi ce constructeur bois comme
j'avais eu cet appel cette affinité avec
l'allemagne j'ai eu là aussi c'est là
les rencontres de la vie j'ai eu
l'opportunité après être revenu au siège
ou peut-être là je prendrai un petit peu
moins de plaisir parce que c'était un
poste plus peut-être plus fonctionnel
moi j'avais plutôt un goût pour pour
l'opérationnel
donc là j'ai eu l'opportunité de renouer
finalement avec l'opérationnel en
redevenant patron d'une marque et
ensuite d'un groupe qui est le quai le
groupe volkswagen et là aussi ça a été
de nouveau une formidable aventure
professionnelle où j'ai découvert de
l'intérieur après avoir vécu pendant dix
ans en allemagne mais en étant patron
d'une filiale française
en allemagne l'âge était patron d'une
filiale allemande en france donc c'était
différent donc j'ai pu voir les deux
côtés ça m'a passionné de découvrir
comment fonctionne et de l'intérieur un
groupe allemand et un groupe aussi fort
et est fantastique qu'est le quai le
groupe volkswagen
aurez vous avez été touché par la faire
voler la gamme diesel gates en 2015
l'agencé américaine de l'environnement
accuse le groupe volkswagen d'utiliser
un logiciel pour truquer les contrôles
de pollution en rendant les véhicules
moins polluants comment vous avez vécu
cette dalle qu'a dû être difficile quand
même oui bah quand vous êtes patron
d'une filiale commerciale et qu'un
événement comme ça vous tombe dessus du
jour au lendemain alors vous êtes
vraiment bien sûr pas du tout au courant
ou impliqué de quelque nature que ce
soit basse pour un dirigeant c'est une
épreuve
monsieur est d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi sur ce sujet là et j'ai
construit d'ailleurs un petit module de
conférences ou de formation de coaching
pour expliquer aux dirigeants qu'il faut
se préparer parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un monde où des crises y en aura de
plus en plus moi j'ai vécu probablement
the crise avec une crise qui avait des
dimensions multiples et pour un
dirigeant c'est une formidable épreuve
au cours de laquelle finalement vous
vous avez la chance de pouvoir mettre en
pratique tout ce que vous avez appris en
termes de qualité managériale pendant
pendant votre votre parcours au
préalable et moi le message que je donne
aux dirigeants c'est de se préparer de
se former il ya des choses maintenant on
peut se promener ceux anticipés parce
que encore une fois des crises y en aura
que ça soit de nature sécuritaire
environnementale financière humaine
il y aura il y aura toutes les
entreprises des organisations seront
touchés par des crises et pour un
dirigeant c'est une épreuve et et que
les qualités des dirigeants s'expriment
bien là en terme de leadership en
situation de crise alors soit vous êtes
un dirigeant talentueux in et vous avez
les bons réflexes et pour être encore
plus performant vaut mieux se préparer
et et moi c'est ce que je joue vraiment
le message que je donne à mes collègues
dirigeants de se préparer de réfléchir à
ce que peut être une crise pour pour
l'heure l'organisation et c'est ce que
vous faites actuellement dans votre
cabinet deux en particulier les uns aux
gens font énormément communiqué faut
être prêt faut être présent le dirigeant
doit être présent pour redonner du sens
là aussi on revient finalement à ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur le rugby
l'important c'est le sens quand une
organisation est impacté par une crise
elle est perdue on health et plus je
sais plus où elle habite quelque part et
donc le tout le monde se tourne vers le
dirigeant tous les regards se tournent
vers lui et le rôle du dirigeant dans
cette situation là c'est vraiment de
communiquer pour redonner du sens de la
confiance rassure et l'organisation
finalement la boucle est bouclée merci
jacques rigaud elle d'avoir participé à
sauver y paie président du groupe
d'intérêt public en charge d'organiser
la coupe du monde de rugby en 2023 en
france
[Musique]